it's a rainy day in london we haven't
play-tested this at all i have no idea
if this is going to work but this is
aaron from mr who's the boss hello and
you have an air tag i do so this is
basically a low-power bluetooth tracker
and i'm going to stick it in tom's
pocket and see if i can find you the
producers have put together a list of
things to do in london i've got one hour
from when i see that list to do as much
of it as i can and all aaron has to do
is catch me
how confident are you i feel great
because i just realized tom has an
iphone and these things get their
location by pinging off iphones so every
time i open this up for google maps
i'm going to know where you are every
time i walk past someone with any apple
device yep
all right it's in the pocket
one hour on the clock and i've got a
three minute head start
this is now you stretching
this is this is gonna look rough and
ready because all we have on cameras
here are one gopro for each of us
following
so if you want to get the timer ready
yup
one hour yep
three
two
one go
oh so let's go ahead okay so we gotta
give him three minutes he said he's a
fast runner right so i've only got three
minutes before he's on the move so first
step
is go underground where this isn't gonna
work right away as soon as he turns his
phone off we're gonna struggle to track
him like as accurately
it's not a beating
tom dance draw busker take yourself with
us chuck oh blimey there's so many
things here this is a lot of challenges
though closest one is feet right feed
the ducks in the royal park
i don't need something
salute to garden bucking past we got
we're going to buckingham palace that's
happening okay so i'm going to check the
list to see where he's going green park
i need green park three minutes feels
like such a long time
[Music]
this requires london geography
he's had several minutes to think
whereas i just panicked and ran and i
think
that might have been a bad idea i'm
gonna have to google a lot of these
things the good news is
as soon as i'm on this train he's not
going to get this train and he's not
going to be able to track me
but
he'll know i'm on the tune he's in the
station he's in the station okay
but where's he going alright we should
probably get started all right
could you imagine if we got on the same
train as him
this is some much needed cardio the tube
is so fast and yet feels so slow right
now this is
incredibly frustrating on the bright
side though as part of this game tom can
only use each form of public transport
once i don't think it's going to be like
that accurate tracking i i trust these
air tags
sorry excuse me
so the reason i pick carving garden is i
think quite a few things on this list he
could do that it feels like candidate
number one
feed the ducks
mimic a statue there will be a statue in
common garden
one more stop isn't it okay easy first
point
imitate a statue
this is where london knowledge comes in
handy
two more stops might as well get a seat
what have we got we got uh
facing this way going to be using these
turned that way
that it turns out is a very very
difficult position about do you think
that's close enough do i get the point
yeah good enough that's one this way he
could go on the bus but
you're almost fast at walking in london
he could take a bike he's a bit of a
rogue character
tom scott could do anything
i did not realize
quite how paranoid i'd be how quickly
because
this is i know like the worst case
absolute worst case is one train behind
me
but this is a very
big
open space
and i am now
very trackable all right tom scott i'm
coming for you
or maybe we're on the other side of
london we'll find out ah
have i got time
to the stairs
i don't have time i don't have time is
this an exit i don't know
all right
what is this
ah buckingham palace
the pain the pain tom are you done to me
guard
guard knee guard
[Music]
no i realize i should have
i should have taken the lift
i don't suppose you've got any that's
why you've only like snacks on you for
duck feeding or anything like that have
you because ah milky way
is it okay to feed a milky way bar to
ducks okay
so we're in carbon garden now
about to check the air tag location
hopefully he's here
[Music]
hey siri can ducks eat chocolate so the
air tag is still putting his location as
the underground which means
he might not have got out the train here
why are you giving me the nutrition
information for a duck what do we do now
then what if he's just doing a lap of
london
even with me being skeptical of how good
the air tag is aaron
must have got a low case you must know
i'm in this area by now so
let's get it
let's feed a duck and get out that is a
pigeon
my confidence levels are dropping
that is a crow
[Music]
that's a goose there's got to be a duck
around here somewhere ah tom is not
updating no
you know what he's done he's probably
turned his phone on airplane mortgage
top chocolate is toxic to livestock like
ducks
[Music]
looks like a shop
that's a coot those are swans those are
where are the where are the ducks today
on i identified birds so the issue is if
thomas put his phone on airplane mode
then we can't rely on the air tag to
constantly ping his location from his
iphone so we've instead gotta wait for
him to pass other people with iphones
for that airtight to ping the location
off them let's just go towards the water
and hope he pops up
yes i got a receipt it's a business
expense this is a business expense slice
of carrot cake where are the doctors
there are the ducks what is our best
shot
we just got out running can i see aaron
anywhere
i don't
i don't see him oh oh okay it's updated
queen victoria and memorial
he's not far he's not far duck island is
where he is
he's feeding the ducks he is
duck
duck
go on
that's a point
so it looks like thomas managed to sneak
in a cheeky little uh duck feeding
session on the way down but we're going
to cut him off before he gets to the
thames this way it's in james park
station awesome do you want some carrot
cake
there we go okay he's moving i can see
him moving
can we go to westminster station please
what can we get around here because i
can't take the tube again so
across the thames
visit a famous boat there must be a
tourist tat shop there where i can get a
stupid hat
change one eye yeah all right
south
oh
also parrots
youtube guy yeah i know you're also in
the middle of a chase game right now but
and enjoy the parakeets
so three of the tasks involve this river
right here and we're basically guarding
the waterway to make sure he doesn't get
these done
i just know there's gonna be
somewhere in this video there's gonna be
just this
devastating shot out of a cab window as
he goes down past there i'm
paranoid of every cab now
okay it's just updated again he's that
way
right oh he's updated going strand
apparently that's close
okay
i don't see him i don't see him okay i
think the world's smallest police
station is around here i don't see him i
don't see him
point and run
[Music]
probably there
i still don't see him
okay you said you can't cover london on
foot
okay there are two choices that with the
time left there's only
two maybe three i can get
across the thames uh recite a line of
shakespeare at the globe that's down
there but that's a long way or buy a
gift for aaron from common garden that's
a time waster
change one item with clothes that's two
in covent garden
and then
cross the thames from there
covent garden it's right there it's
right there
[Music]
i hate to say this but i think it may be
time to run again
ah traffic
here we go
we're as close as we've been right now
all right i need to buy a gift for aaron
i need to get a bit of clothing for
myself i mean i should really go to the
apple store and get him an air tag but i
think he's already got about ten of them
okay
[Music]
thank you is it possible to get a
printed receipt though please thank you
[Music]
this is the team's new production office
where all the prep for the videos on
this channel happens and this is the new
office decoration that i'm putting up
today thanks to displate for sponsoring
this video displate make posters made of
beautifully printed metal
which elevates these way above anything
you'd normally find on an office wall
and the mounting system uses fancy
magnets so you don't need any tapes or
hammers or power tools to put them up
you just
put them in place you can also use their
new 3d magnets to make it seem like the
post is hovering away from the wall
these are the medium sized ones which
fit nicely on our panels here they're
also available in larger sizes and
framed up if you like in either gloss or
matte to fit your wall for the office we
went for the light map of london which
looks spectacular printed up on metal
like this and
this beautiful bit of art by frank moth
they've also got officially licensed
posters from star wars marvel dc and a
load of movies and video games and i
also got this print of nasa's grand tour
design from the jet propulsion
laboratory uh but i'm taking this one
home you can go to the link in the video
description to get a discount and see
the displays that the team and i here
recommend right back to the show
right okay got him a gift
i'm now terrified that he has while i
was in there talking to the wonderfully
chatty but unfortunately that's not what
i really wanted at that moment the the
unfortunately chatty shop assistant that
he ran by got the photo and moved on and
is now tracking me we've got to find him
at least we've got to just see tom scott
it's like a it's like a mirage at this
point come on let's go
where are all the tourist tat shop
london transport museum
if he's found me by now i'm done for now
thank you can i get a receipt please
do i see him can i see him
i don't see him anyway i'm going to
sneak down this this corner
and
on the assumption he hasn't got eyes on
me
right now
i hate this hat but nevertheless that's
i think a point oh god
my london geography is terrible
if i've known this i would have revised
if i got the wrong way i think i've got
the wrong way
if aaron's smart
and he's tracking me
then he'll see me going south there's
only
only like one possible route i could be
taking now i think
i think if i've missed a really obvious
strategy it's gonna be really annoying
look how close we are
come on tom come on anywhere here
just want to see him at this point
will it be quicker to find a bus stop up
there's the bus stop all right bus stop
south that will be
should be
quicker overall
i am watching you tom
i'm ready
any bus going to waterloo and he must
literally any bus from this stop
no hang on
one one eighty eight sixty eight one
sixty eight performing two forty three
one that must do
victory any person here could be him
he's moved a little bit more let's go
let's run
the driver has been told to wait at this
bus stop for a short time to help even
out the service
we apologize for any inconvenience to
your journey oh do you
i'd like to think i've made smart
decisions in this game and i really i
really don't think i have
no oh
wait
i can't tell is that him this is a bad
decision this was such a bad every
every other bus is going by i should
have got off this one we are literally
one minute away from him come on okay we
have eight minutes left we've got to do
this
okay okay we're moving
we're almost on top of him we should
have playtested this absolutely not
he was last seen here four minutes ago
come on give me something give me
something somewhere down here
i don't see him
i don't see him i don't see him i don't
see him i'm still wearing this stupid
hat aren't i
i don't know okay let's assume river
let's go
the globe is
hopefully less than seven minutes run
that way here we go
oh he could be on a bus
[Music]
there is not a way down here
see if he has actually sat on a bus and
he's not near anyone who has an apple
device
we've got no chance i'll see you at the
globe we're on the way there
this was a bad plan
this is a very bad plan i should have
got a taxi
you
idiot
might as well spend my last minute
enjoying the sights of london
from my side
i've learned
that my planning under pressure is awful
genuinely awful
what's it like a million apple devices
in this city and that
is time
oh no is that my gift i got you a gift
oh no
i've never been so upset to receive
something it was so close
and thank you also
in in a change of pocket
an air tag ah
did you just guess where i was going on
the tube yeah we kind of had to because
the whole time we were like three
minutes behind yeah and because air tags
don't give you direction we just kind of
had to use your kind of like right rough
and you had to look at the list and work
out okay he's probably going to hit
those yeah okay so you could have
followed me home with it but you can't
like live
stalk someone exactly that's what i was
thinking right in theory it should be
really accurate because it's like a
billion devices around the world yeah
but i guess in practice when you're
moving fast maybe it doesn't look
totally trying not to be found yeah with
a lot of walls that's gonna bounce gps
stuff off everything that's also true
yeah i guess the other thing i was
thinking is this doesn't necessarily
prove that it's not a good tracking
device because this time you were aware
that i put one on you oh if i wasn't
the number of times i was going i see
wait run i'm going no i'm by the wall
here i'm going to stay out of the way i
was convinced multiple times that you
were just hiding behind somewhere ready
i am looking forward to seeing this back
and seeing just how close you got yeah
me too
thank you very much man
all right see ya
don't wander off now
we can go to the pub
you